I know magic do sport quite a few points
in the fastbreak that is game
double-teaming him as he goes to the
basket again lays it up and in throw in
another sport actually this video this
cappella he erases it at the basket sets
up a fast break with harden the one man
down
Terrell green in the game two for
Houston he took the first shot he has
there's harden again he got off to a
great start gerald head now he's kind of
playing the role where he's got from the
three-point line they're doing a good
job at knocking down some threes but
early in the shot clock maybe not but
laying the shot
oh pretty much whatever they want and
they're shooting a really high percent
well again three but on the other side
of it is they don't guard the paint
burrs harden just pumps his band off
that bootay gets out of the lane now
harden turns around that pace takes it
to the middle close it up in there
Orlando hanging right in harden is open
any fire
not good spacing by the magic now
hardens in a hurry
Martin to the basket pardon for two
[Music]
we can pocket seventh
[Applause]
set fires hips you need to make it one
here looking mystery guys guarding
Harden
at four seconds down to three Harden's
gonna have to take a shot he puts it up
on the magic line up they've got hezonia
playing their center spot so both teams
and small acts Arden with a drive and
against their own the Cloudant of the
temple Martin Van Gogh Simmons no
whistle carving dates it in he's got 54
diligence on that one five seconds down
before down the three card to trying to
step back he does
heart steps back fires
[Music]
kitchen Calvin
[Applause]